what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel um and welcome to
morning water thoughts
um I
wasn't sure if I was going to address
this because I honestly thought it was
really stupid and I didn't really feel
like I owed people an explanation of how
I recruit for my show but
um I've gotten a lot of questions about
it so for the people that are genuinely
curious
um and not accusing me of things I will
tell you
so
recruiting is the hardest part of
running a live show
I promise to God you cannot be that
picky with recruiting you can't because
getting people four times a week in
studio is incredibly difficult
incredibly difficult that is the hardest
part of the job
so when I first started
um what I did was I
um recruited people through Instagram so
when this is when the show is in its
very very early stages and I would do
that by having the same message I would
copy and paste to basically anyone in
London and the way I would do that is I
would look at people on my volleyball
team or people that went to my school
and I would look at who they followed so
I would like copy and paste same message
until someone said yes
I had a harder time recruiting girls
guys were a lot easier to recruit so
you'll see in the early days of the show
a lot of times there's a lot more men
than women
um back then I did everything that was a
good thing came on back then I did
everything myself so it was very
stressful I was doing Clips I was doing
thumbnails like everything I was just
doing myself
so the first chance I got I outsourced I
was like I am Outsourcing everything
immediately I hired a recruiter his name
was Eddie a lot of you guys would DM him
to come on the show he still helps us
from time to time
and it was his job to bring in guests so
once he started that was like July I
really didn't know who's coming
um there were some days if we were low
on guests or like we just had a bad day
I have like
you'll notice them they'll be like
regulars on the show there's like 10
maybe 20 people that I know will come
like last minute because they live
nearby so forever low I'll text them
message them
um
then
um recently we hired an agency and the
reason being we hired the agency was we
just had too many people that agreed on
a show and I just don't think it's
productive
um to have a conversation where everyone
agrees like I just think it's kind of
boring and those are boring shows and I
think what's interesting is you can
bring people on two opposite ends of
that Spectrum
um to disagree
I don't care if it's a 304 only fans
model I don't care if it's a educated
the Oxford feminist I've had those on
the show
um I don't care if they disagree with me
because they believe in polygamy I don't
care if they disagree with me because
um
anything really I prefer people that
disagree I think it makes for better
content and I think it makes for better
conversations so when I tell my
recruiters I tell them the number one
thing is that I want people that
disagree with me
that is the only and I like talking to
more women than men because
um women they just tend to how to put it
show up less so I always say to like
overbook on women because typically they
have like a higher flake rate in general
um all women
and to the people that accuse me of only
having one type of woman on my show
clearly clearly has not watched my show
um
because
I have regular women that are clearly
not 304s
um
my friend Jess she works with me she's
always on the show she's not a three and
four
um my
we're helping one girl start a channel
her name's auntie
she's like a 50 year old lady and she
just you know it's very opinionated and
funny so I
again I don't even know if this video is
worth making but I just got so many
questions on the recruiting process and
accusations without even asking me so
that's that's how I recruit so yeah
every day I don't know who's coming I
say to prioritize women and prioritize
people that disagree
and I have a list of regulars that if
all else fails can come on the show
those are men and women I don't even
think
I think there's maybe two or three that
are quote unquote 304s but I don't I
wouldn't even go that far I would just
say they're more like feminists than
304s but
yeah that's that's um
that's how I recruit so if you guys are
curious
there it is okay bye